russia's invasion of ukraine is
worsening the global threat of hunger
and starvation russia and ukraine are
major suppliers of wheat cooking oil and
other food staples exports are now being
disrupted pushing prices higher and
making food more unaffordable for the
world's most impoverished people now
humanitarian relief is also being
affected in 2021 ukraine was the largest
single source of food for the un's world
food program which works to feed the
most vulnerable around the world
now in eastern africa the situation is
particularly dire the effects of climate
change are being compounded by regional
conflicts and now the knock-on effects
of russia's war in europe are
exacerbating the crisis now while part
of the region is experiencing its worst
drought in 40 years south sudan has been
hit by severe flooding now that makes
outside supplies of food and grain even
more vital
near local garden is flooded
she tries desperately to rebuild her
small embankment
in her village paguir residents have
built canoes to move themselves around
as their cattle perish in the flood
waters it's the third year in a row that
they've had to fight the effects of
heavy flooding
the water's taken everything from me
my land my home my food was swept away
the floods came two years ago
since then we've lived in water we try
our best but the water beats us
a large part of south sudan has been hit
by the worst flooding in 60 years
nearly a million people are suffering
the consequences
the catastrophe has hit a country in
which millions are starving and
impoverished
south sudan has the highest poverty rate
in the world
eighty percent of people live on less
than two dollars a day
now food prices are rising
grain comes from neighboring countries
who themselves import wheat from russia
and ukraine
years of armed conflict have meant that
very few crops are grown in south sudan
it's almost totally dependent on imports
and it's often lowest in the food chain
we're witnessing the worst hunger crisis
to date in south sudan over 8 million
people are extremely hungry and this
includes tens of thousands of people who
could starve if we're unable to reach
them with good assistance
we're seeing people's resilience fading
in the face of the ongoing conflict the
floods and rising food prices
food packages from aid organizations are
reaching only a fraction of south
sudan's 12 million people
many of whom are in great need
as the rainy season begins again
we can take a closer look at this with
martin frick director of the un's world
food program here in germany welcome to
dw um if i can start with the fact that
your organization the world food program
delivers food assistance to more than 80
countries how are you managing this
current situation
well we are administrating a lack
actually um already in december we were
in the very dire position that in
yemen we had to cut rations for 8
million people to take from hungry
people to delivery to the starving for
this year we estimate that we are 50
under finance
turning to ukraine can you tell us more
about what the war means for countries
like egypt or lebanon that normally get
the vast majority of their grain from
ukraine
that's right if you look at the map
ukraine is the closest big crane
provider for the middle east northern
africa region now as we speak four and a
half million tons of wheat are still
blocked in the black sea
ports and at the same time the lack of
ukrainian ukraine but also unilateral
decisions of russia not to export
has driven up wheat prices in a time
when we have already witnessed for last
year
a steep increase in wheat prices
this is compounded by
conflicts by the effects of covet that
have pushed many african countries so
deeply into debts that they can
basically not get money on international
money markets
what would you say is the larger problem
at the moment is it the disruption of
wheat production inside ukraine or is it
the fact that russia is actually
blocking the country's ports and
preventing all wheat exports from
leaving
the wheat exports is currently i think
the bigger problem and one that could be
immediately solved if we had safe access
to ships to give you an idea before the
war only the port of odessa has handled
four crane ships a day with an
equivalent of two hundred thousand
tonnes and this is now not possible um
neighboring countries also austria and
germany are looking into
train transports to compensate but the
capacities are much lower than what
ships could deliver and in addition to
that the space in the silos is being
needed for the next harvest not to risk
that this harvest is being developed
would you go so far as to say that
russia is deliberately triggering a
global food crisis
well
we started off in the war speaking about
collateral hunger but issues such as
safe passage for ships will be approved
whether this is intentional or it is
only an inverted comma as a side effect
of the wall
now you mentioned that germany is trying
to help ukraine ship more supplies via
rail
will that help and what else needs to be
done
well we have estimated that by rail we
could maybe get out about 1 million
tons of wheat but in the port cities at
the black sea there is at least four and
a half million tons and the new harvest
coming in so we need fundamentally more
capacity to really compensate what has
been lost in the last weeks
over the past decade or so the world has
made real progress in fighting hunger
and malnutrition in your assessment has
that progress now been lost
absolutely and it's really concerning
two years ago we spoke about 811 million
people being food insecure kovit has
certainly added way more than 160
million to that and now also with the
beginning of the ukraine war we
unfortunately estimate that even more
people pushed into food insecurity for
us as the world food programme it means
when we had to look after
basically 150 million people two years
ago in january that was already 276
million people and we are now um rapidly
approaching one third of a billion
people 330 million people who are so
acutely in food insecurity that they
can't do without external help
staggering statistics we'll have to
leave it there martin frick with the
united nations world food programme
thank you so much for talking with dw
thank you
you